des fouilles systématiques à la
recherche d'armes de projectiles
objectif identifier les manifestants qui
souhaitent en découdre et les arrêtés
sur le champ des centaines
d'interpellations pour de la journée
suivie de détention préventive prévenir
plutôt que guérir un changement complet
de stratégie de la part des forces de
l'ordre la semaine dernière gardé à
l'écart des champs elysées les gilets
jaunes peuvent cette fois ci y défiler
pacifiquement pour exprimer leurs
revendications leur ras-le-bol
à l'heure actuelle je travaille avec mon
argent je n'ai plus assez pour vivre ma
grande ma mère c'est pareil elle est
obligée d'élever mes enfants parce qu'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de travail à rien
du tout on est dans la misère à l'heure
actuelle en france un message adressé au
président macron c'est le peuple de
france qui est là et ça il s'y attendait
pas et ça c'est très grave et s'il ne
fait rien ça va aller beaucoup plus loin
cette semaine on nous laisse passer et
on nous laisse prouver que l'on peut
défiler pacifiquement sans tout casser
mais le calme ne dure qu'un temps
les détonations grenades lacrymogènes
ce fonds bientôt entendre des tirs de
balles de caoutchouc bossi
sept manifestantes étaient une centaine
de mètres elle est atteinte au visage
blessé sérieusement elle a pris en
pleine tête le défigurer c'est la
conscience qu'ils font là rapidement les
esprits s'échauffent
la tension monte
regardez une charge de plusieurs
centaines de gendarmes de crs donc coach
de lens
[Musique]
l'air est saturé de gaz lacrymogène donc
on l'avait dit un que sa lettre est très
mobile
c'est très mobiles les forces de l'ordre
se déplace en permanence pourchasse ceux
qui sont considérés comme des casseurs
les gens qui ont un peu violence ceux
qui lancent des projectiles comme ça
repoussé disperser les casseurs sème la
destruction sur leur passage
commerces saccagés voitures incendiées
les policiers établissent des périmètres
de sécurité pour permettre aux pompiers
de faire leur travail
alors que les affrontements se déplace
un peu plus loin une réactivité des
forces de l'ordre qui a permis selon les
autorités de limiter la casse la
priorité donnée aux interpellations à la
fois vont les aimer demain mais
également pendant les événements a
montré sa capacité dissuasive
il est 18 heures et quelques poussières
ici les gendarmes sont en train
d'avancer après avoir inondé l'air de
gaz lacrymogènes il avance pour dégager
les champs-elysées des derniers
manifestants
la nuit tombée les lumières de noël
donne une ambiance surréaliste sur une
avenue des champs elysées paris cadet
est déserte
l'affrontement semble terminé pour la
soirée mais la tension en france elle
reste entière et si jean françois
bélanger radio-canada paris